jetzt gleich startet die generaldebatte
im bundestag und hier sehen wir auch
schon das livebild das kommen mal ein
blenden aus dem bundestag und sobald es
losgeht gehen wir natürlich live drauf
friedrich merz wird sprechen und
natürlich auch bundeskanzler olaf scholz
es geht gleich um den haushalt von 3,9
milliarden und heute abgesegnet werden
soll aber es geht natürlich eigentlich
auch um viel viel mehr der in der kritik
stehende kanzler scholz muss jetzt seine
ukraine politik und auch für seine
ausgaben verteidigen es dürfte also hoch
hergehen wir sehen jetzt also schon
bärbel bas die sich auf den weg macht
die bundestagspräsidentin und bei uns im
studio begleitet wird das ganze unsere
chefreporter peter thelen peter bevor es
losgeht schon mal eine frage an dich was
erwartest du das jetzt eine richtig
spannende debatte heute wird es hoch her
gehen also hoch weiß ich nicht aber
zumindest ist das also es fängt an und
zwar mit dem einzelplan 04 das ist der
etat des bundeskanzlers und das ist
traditionell die stunde der opposition
da setzt man sich komplett auseinander
mit der politik die generalabrechnung
normalerweise mit die bundeskanzlerin
mit seiner politik erwarten darf man das
erwarten muss man das gerade in solchen
zeiten natürlich hat man sich gerade
erst geeinigt friedlich schiedlich auf
100 milliarden extra programm für die
deutsche bundeswehr die will man
erneuern und in dem zusammenhang ist es
da natürlich vielleicht nicht ganz so
scharf aber es gibt genügend abzurechnen
gerade mit der politik von bundeskanzler
scholz in sachen ukraine mit seiner
unklare position wir hatten jetzt in der
welt gestern gerade darin die große
umfrage im kabinett soll die ukraine den
krieg gewinnen ja oder nein ganz
einfache frage gefeiert wurde von den
regierungskoalitionen mit wenigen
ausnahmen die idee fdp weiter klar eine
spd ministerin war klar alle anderen
haben sich gedrückt ganz klare ansage
war die opposition war die cdu und von
daher davon heute scharfe töne erwarten
und du hast ja extra zwei kaffee
mitgebracht heute morgen hat es heiß
hergehen wird hier die braucht man dann
gerne morgen wie wie heute was wären
denn die konkreten punkte von friedrich
merz seien dann also friede schmerzen
muss natürlich auf die ukraine politik
gehen er muss auch die haushaltspolitik
draufgehen es werden schulden gemacht
wir sind in einer schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen lage wird sie haben
super inflation die leute wissen nicht
mehr wie die sich ihr normales leben
leisten können sollen weiterhin gerade
die normal und die unteren verdiener
gruppen sind stark betroffen die müssten
eigentlich noch mehr entlastet werden
heute beginnt der große tank rabatt also
genügend angriffsfläche und schon geht's
los im bundestag dann haben wir
deutschland schnellste meinung natürlich
vergangenen sonntagabend
konnten wir unter lauter mit den
koalitionsfraktionen auch die
einzelheiten einer grundgesetzänderung
zur errichtung eines sondervermögens
verständigen mit dem die ausrüstung und
die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
zusätzlich mit 100 milliarden euro
ausgestattet werden dieser sonntag war
und ist zuallererst ein guter tag für
die bündnisse und verteidigungsfähigkeit
unseres landes unter ist ein guter tag
für die bundeswehr
ich will an dieser stelle herzlich dank
sagen an diejenigen die auf unserer
seite der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
die gespräche mit den
koalitionsfraktionen geführt haben
unsere kollegen alexander dobrindt
mathias middelberg zur wadephul und
florian hahn herzlichen dank dafür dass
sie die verhandlungen zielorientiert und
konstruktiv in unser aller namen gefüllt
haben
ebenfalls ein dank sagen an die
koalitionsfraktionen
dass sie bereit waren unseren wünschen
vollumfänglich zu folgen was die
ausgestaltung dieses sondervermögen hoch
her gibt es hier natürlich nicht
friedlich in alpbach 20 das haben
eigentlich erst einmal 100 milliarden
hat man sich eigentlich extra für die
bundeswehr grundgesetz musste geändert
werden da kommt ein bisschen eigen lob
und dank an die opposition und danach
müsste jetzt eigentlich losgehen
die
die bundeswehr wird erstmalig in ihrer
geschichte ein
finanzierungsgesetz bekommen indem
klargestellt wird dass deutschland auch
nach der erschöpfung dieser 100
milliarden euro alle verpflichtungen
gegenüber der nato auch in zukunft
einhalten wird und das können auch mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes sein meine damen
und herren und das ist ein guter
vorschlag gewesen die sich gar nicht
erst ins vorgetragen wird
jetzt wird darüber hinaus bis zur
sommerpause und der bundeskanzler da
sehen wir sie in der pflicht das
wirklich auch einzuhalten was ihr
verhandlungsführer zugesagt haben einen
vorschlag zur reform des
beschaffungswesens geben den sehen wir
als notwendig und als dringlich an es
wird schließlich eine bereinigung des
haushaltsausschusses mit einem
unterausschuss geben an der einzelnen
finanzierung und es wird abschließend
der bundesfinanzminister einen
tilgungsplan geben den sie ebenfalls
zugesagt
besser hätten wir es nicht zu einem
abschluss gemeinsam dringend können
herzlichen dank nochmal auch an ihre
adresse weiter mit vorsicht
hätten wir uns gewünscht dass auch im
hinblick auf die unmittelbare
herausforderung
der wir in diesen tagen und wochen
gestellt sind nämlich der eindämmung des
krieges in der ukraine
ähnlich klare und eindeutige politische
entscheidungen in deutschland
getroffen worden wären wir hätten uns
allen gewünscht meine damen und herren
dass die bundesregierung dem wunsch und
dem auftrag des deutschen bundestages
nachgekommen wäre den wir wenn auch herr
bundeskanzler in ihrer abwesenheit am 28
april ebenfalls in großer
übereinstimmung hier im deutschen
bundestag in einem entschließungsantrag
formuliert haben wir haben zur
erinnerung unter anderem beschlossen
neben der humanitären und finanziellen
hilfe der ukraine auch schwere waffen zu
liefern damit dieses land sich gegen die
russische aggression ausreichend und
erfolgreich verteidigen kann
so haben sie es hier gemeinsam ich bin
gespannt
wie möglich feststellen mehr als einen
monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht gewinnt
und dann war friedrich merz einen ganz
ganz wichtigen punkt in seiner ruhigen
art er hat ja nicht volle möhre drauf
aber da könnte man draufhauen aber das
saß und zwar am 28 04 sagt friedrich
merz hat der bundestag in ihrer
abwesenheit der bundeskanzler
beschlossen dass man schwere waffen
geliefert werden sollen und es werden
keine schweren waffen beliefert ganz
klar ab und wir friedrich merz
keine schweren waffen gelte für die
ukraine ihre parteivorsitzende
bundeskanzler sagt auch andere länder
würden keine schweren waffen liefern sei
zwar keine formale vereinbarung aber so
eine art informelle vereinbarung dass
diese waffen nicht geliefert werden und
sie herr bundeskanzler reden in letzter
zeit etwas mehr als sonst aber sie sagen
unverändert nichts was ist ein wir doch
mal sehen was da als die koalition
wer hat man sich um unter den staats und
regierungschefs den abgeordneten in der
europäischen union dann kann ich
feststellen über die haltung der
bundesregierung gibt es mittlerweile nur
noch verstimmungen vorsichtig formuliert
es gibt enttäuschungen über die unklare
rolle deutschlands und es gibt richtig
verärgerung über sie und ihre regierung
und nicht nur während die opposition
sondern abgeordnete aus ihren reihen
herr bundeskanzler machen ihrem ärger
und ihren unmut über das was sie in den
letzten tagen und wochen geschieht immer
lauter oft bis hin zu der wortmeldung
einer europaabgeordneten der kollegin
viola von cramon von den grünen die in
der letzten woche gesagt hat sie
brüsteten sich mit was man bereits für
die ukraine schon alles geleistet habe
sie würden dabei auf absprachen
verweisen mit vermeintlichen partnern
die es überhaupt nicht geht ohne die
hilfe der usa sei die ukraine längst von
russland überrollt worden
abschließendes zitat für deutschland
bleibt jetzt nur noch verachtung übrig
ja das ist nicht aus unseren reihen und
bundesmeister das kommt aus ihre rollen
aus den reihen ihrer
ganz wichtiger punkt friedrich merz geht
ja auf die kritik die es auch von den
grünen vor allem gibt und auch aus der
fdp gibt und aus dem ausland ein olaf
scholz politik und an seine
zögerlichkeit gegenüber der ukraine
und er hat jetzt die
grünen-europaabgeordnete viola von
cramon
zitiert die zu den schärfsten kritikern
gehört ganz wichtiger punkt und dann
noch eine stilfrage lieben bei wende
oppositionsführer spricht dann schreibt
man keine sms der kanzler macht es
trotzdem
den schaden den er gerade nicht abwendet
liegt im ansehensverlust der deutschen
politik
reflektion und vorsicht beschreibt einer
der herausgeber der faz
reflektion um vorsicht gelten nicht ohne
grund als tugenden sie als fassade für
zaudern zu verwenden ist unredlich und
lebendigkeit
unredlich so eine auszeichnung durch
eine große deutsche tageszeitung muss
man sich erstmal verdienen
unredlich steht als synonym für
böswillig verschweigen
unaufrichtig habe
ja meine damen und herren was
verschweigen sie uns eigentlich herr
bundeskanzler
sie telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem
projekt mit dem russischen
staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der parlament der
ukraine nach deutschland nach berlin und
sie verweigern ihm bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin
herr bundeskanzler was ist da eigentlich
los in ihrer regierung ich kann begrenzt
verstehen dass sie nicht nach kiew
reisen dort aber wenn der
parlamentspräsident der zweithöchste
repräsentant der ukraine morgen in
berlin ist warum geben sie dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine keinen
geschlossen was die stadt
regierte
[Applaus]
herr friedrich merz in ganz ruhigen ton
stellt er die grundsätzlichen politik
und die haltung von kanzler oder scholz
und seiner regierung grundlegend in
frage was verschweigen sie uns das ist
schon wirklich anklagen der ton 80
minuten mit putin telefonieren und
keinen termin haben für den
parlamentspräsidenten der und der
ukraine das stellt ihnen fast schon in
die ecke eines vaterlandsverräter dass
er spricht es nicht aus aber es klingt
mit an
[Applaus]
russland warum sagen sie ist nicht ganz
klar russland muss zumindest hinter die
kontakt linie vom 24 februar 2022
zurückgedrängt werden
[Applaus]
auf der welt und in europa es sagen es
ist auch nicht meine oder unsere frage
aber gibt es da mittlerweile eine zweite
agenda warum widerspricht aus ihren
reihen der spd niemand ihrem
amtsvorgänger im amt des bürgermeisters
der freien und hansestadt hamburg klaus
von dohnanyi der hier in diesen tagen
durch berlin von einer talkshow in die
andere geht russland in schutz nimmt
putin verteidigt und fast ausschließlich
den vereinigten staaten von amerika die
schuld an diesem krieg zubeißt herr
bundeskanzler was machen sie da und
warum stellen sie das nicht klar was sie
für eine meinung zu diesem thema
wir haben am 27 februar von dieser
stelle aus eine vielbeachtete
regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im deutschen bundestag sehr viel
zustimmung bekommen
stehenden applaus auch von meiner
fraktion
ja das haben wir wohl zur kenntnis
genommen haben meine damen und herren
aber sie bleiben doch hinter den selbst
gestellten ansprüchen dieses 27 februar
mittlerweile tag für tag immer weiter
zurück sie haben an diesem tag klartext
gesprochen
sie haben die tat gesagt die sind die
lage sehen seit dem fall dampft und
verdunstet das alles was sie da gesagt
haben im unklaren im ungefähren und es
wird keine konkrete entscheidung
getroffen und hier begründet die an
dieses niveau und in diesem level
anschließen sie am 27 februar 2022 hier
selbst gesetzt
ich bin ein zweiter aspekt hinzu fügen
wir sind ja nicht allein auf dieser welt
aber warum gibt es eigentlich warum gibt
es eigentlich von ihrer ganz kurze
erklärung nur hier hat friedlichen als
angespielt auf die berühmte zeitenwende
rede von olaf scholz ihrer gehalten am
vierten tag des krieges am 27 februar
und der vorwurf ich jetzt von friedrich
merz alles was sie damals gesagt haben
heute schaltung braucht verdampft
politik klar zeigt in welche richtung
geht es europa entwickelt werden soll
und welche chancen europa auch in diesem
konflikt sieht für die eigene bessere
integration in der außen- sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitik ich würde es
mal so sagen haben sie eigentlich außer
der
formalen rhetorik irgendeinen vorschlag
wie sich europa in dieser historischen
phase des umbruchs aufstellen und
dauerhaft auch verteidigen kann gibt es
irgendeinen vorschlag aus ihrer
regierung
wählen sie wählen sie wenigstens teile
des geld ist dass wir jetzt in diesem
sondervermögen bereitstellen wollen in
eine europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
ein die es uns erlaubt schritt für
schritt hin zu einer europäischen außen-
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik zu
kommen und in diesem zusammenhang wie
sich die bundesregierung wie werden sie
herr bundeskanzler
wenn ganz kurz friedrich merz sieht
gerade die dritte ebene ein er fing an
mit dem 100 milliarden programm der kann
zum ukraine krieg jetzt ist dabei europa
und sagt klipp und klar herr stolze sie
haben keinen plan für europa sieht sie
sagen überhaupt nicht was wir mit
russland umgehen sollen und da spielt
ganz klar darauf an in deutschland muss
die führungsmacht in europa sein und auf
sich von friedlichen herz versagt olaf
scholz hier die formal vorzubereiten das
ist doch eine zutiefst politische
entscheidung in der aufschwungphase
in der klarheit erwartet
[Applaus]
wenn sie ließ offen lassen wenn die
größte aktion der europäischen union in
dieser frage unklar bleibt und keine
klare antwort gibt dann bleibt es in
ganz europa unklar und dann wird es in
ganz europa keine antwort geben also
bitte sagen sie zu gehen ja meine damen
und herren
doch noch in dem zusammenhang mit dem
bundeshaushalt 2022 stellen sind ihnen
eigentlich die risiken bewusst mit denen
sie diesen bundeshaushalt in dieser
woche hier verabschieden wollen und zwar
auch ganz unabhängig von den neuen
schulden die jetzt mit diesem
sondervermögen gemacht werden es könnte
doch sein der bundeskanzler dass sie
schon in wenigen wochen 60 milliarden
euro für den klima- und energiefonds gar
nicht zur verfügung haben weil ihnen das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht erlaubt
diese mittel aus den corona hilfen aus
dem tiroler hilfen zweck zu entfremden
für entscheidungen ihrer regierung die
eigentlich aus dem normalen haushalt
finanziert werden müssten
ganz ganz kurz ein ordnungshüter es geht
um geld das das friedrich merz gerade
sprach das aus den crooner hilfen
umgewidmet werden soll da gab es ein
notfall und dem möchte man jetzt gerne
für andere hilfen umwidmen und da gibt's
klage vom bundesverfassungsgericht unter
anderem klagt die union darüber märz
gesprochen
und in dem zusammenhang wenn sie damals
nicht aus ideologischen gründen sich
geweigert hätten den soli ganz
abzuschaffen sie hätten heute mit diesem
instrument das sie selbst diskreditiert
haben sie hätten heute mit diesem
instrument ein instrument zur verfügung
mit dem wir wahrscheinlich die neuen
schulden für das sondervermögen
bundeswehr gar nicht helfen aufnehmen
müssen sie hätten uns nämlich den
vorschlag machen können der
bundeskanzler dass wir einen solchen
solidaritäts zuschlag erheben auf die
einkommensteuer und auf die
körperschaftssteuer für die bundeswehr
dann wäre das von heutigen generationen
bezahlt worden was eigentlich aufgabe
der heutigen generation dich und nicht
gelungen fraktion in einigen jahren und
jahrzehnten mühsam
nyse abt 1
[Applaus]
eigentlich kann ganz fix friedrich merz
hat gesagt hat holz wenn sie damals den
solidaritätszuschlag komplett
abgeschafft hätten dann hätten wir heute
einen 9 1 1 führen können für bestimmte
einkommensgruppen für die 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr müssten nicht unsere
kinder und enkel dafür zahlen sondern
wir heute mit unserer arbeit
dieses instrument einfach mutwillig
zerstört haben was sagen sie eigentlich
ein bundeskanzler der jungen generation
dass sie es erneut versäumt auch mit
diesem bundeshaushalt eine reform der
renten
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation was sagt
generation dass sie es erneut versäumt
eine reform der rentenversicherung
vorzulegen die einerseits den
bundeszuschuss begrenzt und andererseits
der jungen generation eine sichere
altersversorgung ermöglicht auch hier
eine zahl die steuer
es gibt ich kann das ich kann das gut
verstehen das ist nicht nur da sondern
auch da auf der regierungsbank gehörige
unruhe gibt sie müssen sie müssen sie
müssen mehr als 100 milliarden euro pro
jahr an zuschuss in die
rentenversicherung zahlen es gibt bis
heute keinen vorschlag aus ihrer
koalition diese rentenversicherung zu
reformieren der letzte reformvorschlag
ist an ihnen gescheitert und an ihnen
der bundeskanzler in der letzten
koalition
wir hätten hier längst an reform machen
müssen sie ist an ihnen gescheitert sie
haben ihre zustimmung verweigert um
gegen reformvorschlag der gemacht worden
ist und so bleibt heute festzustellen
das wort zeitenwende dass sie am 27
februar
2022 geprägt und verwendet haben dieses
fonds zeitenwende bleibt außer neuen
schulden für dieses sondervermögen mehr
oder weniger beziehungslos im raum
stehen es gibt nichts was sie außer
neuen schulden mit diesem wort zeigten
verwende zeitenwende ernsthaft verbindet
alles
sowohl film bleiben wie sie es in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag der mittlerweile nur
noch ins archiv gehört wie sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben im
gegenteil aus ihren reihen kommen fast
im wochenrhythmus neue vorschläge wie
man zusätzliches geld ausgibt der
jüngste vorschlag ihres sozialministers
ein soziales klima geld für einkommen
bis 8000 euro im monat
[Applaus]
schauen sie sich mal die reihen dieser
koalition an bei diesem wort soziales
klima geht wird welche reaktionen dass
hier im hause aus nutzt das internet ist
das nicht
das ist so ganz
vielleicht als partei noch ein bisschen
weiter aber setzt dabei vermehrt für
dieses thema sie machen solche
vorschläge hier und ohne jede
finanzierung einfach zusätzliche neue
schulden das ist die botschaft dieser
regierung von bundeskanzler ich möchte
in einen vorschlag machen zum abschluss
ganz cool jetzt ist der stempel drauf
der lange anlauf genommen fing mit der
zeitenwende rede an des bundeskanzlers
und jetzt sag zeiten wenn du diese worte
kanzler steht die beziehungslos im raum
ist nur noch für 1 für neue schulden
also oder stolz blickt märz abgestimmt
zum tiefe schulden kanzler deutschland
wirklich an die ukraine welche waffen
wollen sie liefern was ist ihre präzise
antwort auf diese frage zweitens
zweitens der bundeskanzler wie werden
sie europäischen rat abstimmen wenn die
frage beantwortet werden muss gibt es
für die ukraine und andere staaten den
beitritt status den kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union und dritte frage
auf die auch die viki ist heute morgen
abweichend vom vorgetragenen
vorgelesenen redemanuskript ihr zu
beantworten welche vorschläge machen sie
zur reform der deutschen
rentenversicherung damit die junge
generation in diesem land eine
perspektive
man hätte sich jetzt in altersteilzeit
in anspruch darauf in einer debatte über
den etat des bundeskanzlers diese fragen
verantwortlich
ja da mache ich die hütte friedrich merz
hat blogger angefangen jetzt sind dann
geschafft langsam langsam steigern den
bundestag in wallung zu bringen
zumindest die drei oppositionsfraktionen
und lehrerschaft so ganz zum schluss
erst den kanzler abständen zum schulden
kanzler und dann hinten raus in drei
aufgaben mit ihm für seine rede die
natürlich längst geschrieben ist aufgabe
1 welche waffen wollen sie der ukraine
liefern verfolgt werden sind
europäischen rat abstimmen wenn es um
den kandidatenstatus für die ukraine für
die mitgliedschaft in der europäischen
union gibt und drittens meine
rentenversicherung und die antworten
hätte herr merz warnt gerne sofort
der bundesregierung der bundeskanzler
oder chance
fährt er märz sie haben sich mit dem
text sehen sie sich vorbereitet haben
wir ein manuskript ja sehr viel mühe
gegeben
allerdings muss man ausdrücklich sagen
das was sie hier vorgetragen hat sind
lauter fragen sie sind hier durch die
sache durch die tänze und haben nichts
konkretes gesagt moabit wäre wirklich
sehr vernünftig gewesen
[Applaus]
wenn sie nicht mit durchkommen immer nur
fragen zu stellen und sich niemals in
irgendeiner frage sinnvoll zu
positionieren und wenn sie es dann
machen dann wird's peinlich anzusehen
ist wir alle lieben deutschen
bundeskanzler nicht mehr verstehen vor
allem nicht wenn er englisch blickt
moratti hat er gefordert mehr fleisch
von friedrich merz damit sie zum
bundeskanzler hat dem russischen
präsidenten telefoniert
und sie kritisieren hier das sich mit
dem russischen präsidenten
telefonieren inserieren das dann sagen
sie ich soll was gemeinsames mit dem
französischen präsident machen und
während sie in ihrer rede dass
insinuiert haben haben sie völlig
übersehen das letzte telefongespräch war
ein gemeinsames mit dem französischen
präsidenten übrigens eine europäische
aktion dieser beiden länder die eine
wichtige rolle für die zukunft europas
spielt
und ganz anders als sie das hier
herstellen der stolz trägt verkauf seien
telefonate zusammen mit manueller kromm
mit ihm geführt hat die beiden
telefonieren ja immer mal regelmäßig mit
herrn putin als europäische das aktion
es ist aber eine deutsch französisch ist
es keine europäische aktion das zu
erklären
den muss man sich ja doch noch mal auf
der zunge zergehen lassen ihr vorschlag
den sie heute hier im deutschen
bundestag gemacht haben ist dass wir die
steuern für fast alle bürgerinnen bürger
über ein soli erhöhen sollen um die
bessere ausrüstung der bundeswehr zu
bezahlen was für ein merkwürdiger
einfallen
[Applaus]
einen ganzen bundestagswahlkampf haben
sie damit geführt zu sagen dass der soli
auch für die leute die 200 und 300
400.000 euro im jahr verdienen weg muss
um dann jetzt vorzuschlagen dass leute
die 70.000 60.000 euro verdient den soli
jetzt aber zahlen sollen damit das jetzt
hier gemacht werden können das ist keine
gute idee
und wer ihre fragen beantworten oder sie
sind alle längst beantwortet bei den
gelegenheiten dazu da waren aber ich
will ausdrücklich dazu sagen eins ist
schon ganz ganz zentral wenn man über
das redet was wir reden auch wenn es um
die verbesserung unserer
verteidigungsanstrengungen geht dann
muss man als oppositionsführer der von
der cdu csu kommt schon sagen die
verteidigungsministerin und minister der
letzten jahre waren in der cdu und der
csu die kanzlerin weil der cdu
und darüber hätten sie auch noch wenig
sein wort verlieren märz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der kanzler punktet auf und zwar mit den
ganz kleinen verweis darauf lieber herr
merz die letzten verteidigungsminister
waren von dieser partei oder super
position also die schotten ii geht auch
auf ihr konto ganz startpunkt oder
schulz
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
hat begonnen als ein presse china viel
kommunizieren da selten sich in seinem
amt aufhalten
bundesverteidigungsminister guttenberg
entschieden hat alles mögliche anders zu
machen ordentlich einzusparen die
wehrpflicht abzuschaffen und darunter
leiden wir noch heute dass all das geld
tragen als zusammengestrichen worden
manchmal ist sacharbeit wirklich eine
nützliche sache heraus
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die preise für benzin und diesel für
lebensmittel und fürs heizen steigen
rasant und millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger fragen sich jeden tag komme ich
hin mit meinem geld reicht es noch am
monatsende
das sind sehr sehr sehr gravierende
fragen fragen auf die es in der tat eine
klare antwort braucht die
bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
entlastung von bürgern und bürger und
unternehmen auf den weg gebracht in der
summe reden wir über mehr als 30
milliarden euro
und diese entlastungen kommen jetzt an
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
rückwirkend ab januar wird die
pendlerpauschale erhöht um die hohen
spritpreise etwas auszugleichen am
ersten juli werden die stromrechnung
günstiger weil wir die eeg-umlage
streichen eine vierköpfige familie spart
zu mehrere hundert euro im jahr und ab
juli bekommen bürgerinnen und bürger mit
kleinen einkommen wohngeld
empfängerinnen und studierende mit bafög
ein zuschuss zu den heizkosten
familien werden gezielt entlastet durch
den kinderbonus von armut betroffene
kinder und jugendliche erhalten sofort
zuschlag und zwar monatlich jeder
beschäftigte erhält ab september zum
ausgleich für die gestiegenen
energiekosten einmalig 300 euro
ausgezahlt und schon heute treten zwei
maßnahmen kraft über die wohl am meisten
geredet worden es in deutschland in den
vergangenen wochen die steuersenkung auf
benzin und diesel und das neun euro
ticket im öpnv
die nicht aufs auto also nicht kanzler
wäre und würde ich genauso machen ganz
schnell den bogen vom und angenehm
ukraine krieg und diesen lästigen machen
thema hin zu den sachen die wir ganz
geschlossen haben nämlich schöne hilfen
für die leute die von der super
inflation und von diesen energiepreis
schossen wirklich hart getroffen sind
olaf scholz hat das aufgelistet das geht
auch tatsächlich auf sein konto dass er
seine koalition hat beschlossen benötigt
für mittlere und untere einkommen das
reparierte jetzt völlig zu recht
weil die öffentlichkeit
ihre eigenen themen hat diskutieren denn
die scheiben der öffentlichkeit ist es
so dass das vielleicht noch nicht so
präsent geworden es immer wenn das geld
denn jetzt gezahlt wird dann hoffe ich
wird den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
diese hilfe wirklich dringend brauchen
auch sichtbar es kommt und das haben wir
gemacht übrigens profitieren auch die
renten und rentner von den entlastungs
paketen bei den stromrechnungen vom tank
rabatt und dem neuen euro ticket und zum
ersten juli steigen die renten so stark
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht um 6,1
prozent 12 prozent im osten und über
5,35 im westen für drei millionen
rentnern rente haben wir höhere
erwerbsminderungsrenten auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden das rentenniveau
bei 48 prozent stabilisieren damit es
nicht nach 2025 unterschritten wird das
ist eine wichtige leistung dieser region
[Applaus]
wer sein leben lang gearbeitet und
beiträge gezahlt hat der muss sich auf
seine oder ihre rente verlassen können
das ist ein kernversprechen des
sozialstaates wir werden das erneuern
und in diesen zeiten wo große
veränderung stattfinden da ist es umso
wichtiger dass sich alle verlassen
können auf sicherheit und ja auch
wirklich märz nach der rente gefragt und
was sagt der kanzler wir werden das alte
renten versprechen erneuern dass die
rente sicher ist wer sein leben lang
gearbeitet hat und eingezahlt hat
verdienen soll die rente sicher sein
er sagt es nicht
unter die arme zu greifen
mit dem ähnlichen instrumenten haben es
geschafft durch die korona pandemie zu
kommen und es ist gelungen arbeitsplätze
zu erhalten das ist eine gute botschaft
vor allem wenn wir jetzt sagen können
die beschäftigung es gegenwärtig höher
als vor der pandemie es zeigt wenn ein
land zusammenhält dann kann man auch
durch schwere krisen kommen und diesen
weg dann wir weiter verfolgen
aber ich sage ganz offen
natürlich ist damit das problem
steigender preise noch nicht gelöst
denn der preisanstieg hat eine ganze
reihe von ursachen
ganz vorn der von russland angezettelten
krieg
was machen sie der von russland
angezettelten krieg
[Applaus]
er hat die energie und rohstoffpreise an
die internationalen lieferketten sind
oft noch durch die pandemie gestört
insbesondere in asien man sollte sich
nur einmal die vorstellung
vergegenwärtigen von den vielen schiffen
in den container hilfen chinas
insbesondere in shanghai und natürlich
haben die milliardenschweren
konjunkturpakete die viele länder nicht
nur wir aufgelegt haben dazu geführt
dass es eine höhere nachfrage gibt zum
beispiel nach rohstoffen
noch sind also diese preissteigerung
wahrscheinlich auf solche einmaligen
shops zurückzuführen aber wir müssen
aufpassen
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass daraus
keine dauerhafte entwicklung mit zu
hohen inflationsraten teil bei allem was
wir heute und auch künftig tun ist eins
klar
kreditfinanzierte dauersubventionen sind
keine lösung zumal wir nächstes jahr die
verfassungsmäßig vorgeschriebenen
schuldenbremse wieder beachtet werden
ziel muss also sein den inflationsdruck
nachhaltig zu mildern und zugleich
behalten wir weiterhin die finanzielle
lage von rentnerinnen und rentnern von
grundsicherungsempfänger von
studentinnen und studenten und familien
genau im blick auch die arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmer fragen sich was sie
sich noch mehr leisten können die
tarifpartner in der chemieindustrie
haben kürzlich ein sehr interessanten
weg gewählt
beschlossen wurden gestiegene preise
schnell und substanziell auszugleichen
über eine einmalige sonderzahlung auch
in der stahlindustrie wird darüber
gerade diskutiert auch in anderen
tarifen zum beispiel als ihren haben
einmalige zahlung haben zahlung eine
rolle gespielt
die gute idee dahinter ist den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern
finanziell luft zu verschaffen ohne die
arbeitgeber zu überfordern und
inflationsrisiken anzuheizen
ich habe mich deshalb zusammen mit allen
verantwortlichen der regierung zu einem
ungewöhnlichen schritt entschlossen ich
möchte die arbeitnehmer- und
arbeitnehmer ihre gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber zu einer konzertierten
aktion zusammenrufen
[Applaus]
das hat schon einmal geholfen dass wir
zusammen gestanden haben gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber staat auch viele andere die
verantwortung in diesem land haben um
mit einer schwierigen herausforderung
umzugehen und ich finde es ist richtig
wenn instrumente der zusammenarbeit und
des zusammenhalts von unternehmen von
beschäftigten von gewerkschaften
unternehmerverbänden von start von
kommunen von allen institutionen schon
einmal in schwierigen laden geholfen
haben zu sagen hier muss erneut
zusammengestanden werden und
herausgefunden werden wie wollen wir mit
dieser preisentwicklung umgehend ich bin
dazu bereit dass wir uns so
zusammentreffen
[Applaus]
ja der bundeskanzler kündigt eine
konzertierte aktion dann mit den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitgebern also mit
gewerkschaften und arbeitgebern und der
bundesregierung man wolle zusammenstehen
warum welchem ziel er sagt
sie haben eine große verantwortung dafür
dass die finanzkraft ihrer beschäftigten
groß genug ist aber auch wir als
gemeinschaft und der staat und deshalb
ist es eben umso wichtiger dass wir das
miteinander machen wir brauchen eine
gezielte krankheit kraftanstrengung in
einer ganz außergewöhnlichen situation
und wir sind dazu bereit wir wollen eine
konzertierte aktion gegen den preis
lockt
[Applaus]
das ist natürlich keine lohn
verhandlungsrunde das machen die
tarifpartner aber es geht darum das
miteinander zu besprechen und ich weiß
aus den gesprächen mit den
verantwortlichen im gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbänden und
unternehmensverbänden dass sie das sehr
begrüßen wenn wir genau das jetzt machen
die krone pandemie hat uns gezeigt wie
wichtig gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
ist ich wünsche mir dass wir das
bewahren die aktuelle infektions lage
verschafft uns zeit zum handeln wir
nutzen sie intensiv um uns und unser
gesundheitssystem gut auf herbst und
winter vorzubereiten und sie stellen
unser gesundheitssystem so auf dass es
zukunftssicher ist dazu gehört die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung
verlässlich zu finanzieren
darauf können sich die patienten und
patienten aber auch die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen verlassen die in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren so
unglaublich viel geleistet haben für
unser land und wir werden sie nicht
vergessen und sie weiter unterstütze
alle die sich fragen wohin das jetzt wie
anders das ist ganz klare fakten zum
anfang nimmt der bundeskanzler die
wellen und gewogen von free bieten heißt
es nicht an und dann geht er immer von
der thematisch immer glatter und dem
süßen er jetzt quasi so lange in seiner
rede bisher hinten als der besonderen
urlaub scholz als der stolz kanzler der
merkel nachfolger rauskommt und in der
hoffnung dass jetzt die meisten leute
schon wieder vergessen haben dass
friedrich merz wolle viele bälle
geschlagen hatte
die wir uns als regierung vorgenommen
haben das bürgergeld mit dem wir auf
beratung unterstützung setzen statt auf
unnötige bürokratie und und komplizierte
antragsverfahren und die
kindergrundsicherung die
unübersichtliche vielzahl
unterschiedlicher familienleistungen
zusammenführen und verbessern soll alles
beides wird weiter vorangebracht
kinder und jugendliche die in armut
aufwachsen darf es an einem so reichen
land wie deutschland geben das ist ein
grundsatz der für diese regierung
unabdingbar ead etr
[Applaus]
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu auch
dass wir jetzt
voran bringen was wir uns letztes jahr
vorgenommen haben
nämlich dass diejenigen die am wenigsten
verdienen einen besseren lohn bekommen
der mindestlohn wird ab oktober auf
zwölf euro in der stunde steigen es war
ein langer kampf jetzt wird das realität
das versprechen ist umgesetzt
wir wissen alle dass zwölf euro in der
stunde keine großen sprünge erlauben
aber es ist eine erleichterung für viele
die sehr sehr wenig geld haben gerade
wenn jetzt die preise steigen und es
macht einen unterschied für 6 millionen
bürger und bürger was für eine aussage
über unser land und was hier verdient
wird aber wie dringlich ist diese reform
gut dass jetzt graut
[Applaus]
olaf scholz hat wie empfiehlt kann es da
könnte man indes lang 12 euro
mindestlohn ja sehr schön für ganz viele
und für millionen deutsche aber was da
kannst du nicht dazu sagt das ist ein
politischer preis der festgelegt wurde
ist eigentlich gibt es dafür eine
kommission die soll ihm bestimmen diese
zwölf euro sind politisch gut gemacht
waren eigentlich gehört sich das nicht
auf wenn es den leuten hilft und
eigentlich richtig ist der weg war der
falsche
ich kann das gut verstehen und wir
wissen alle dass wir vor einer zweiten
industriellen revolution stehen nur ein
beispiel um in zukunft mit sauberen
strom betrieben zu werden braucht ein
chemie standort ludwigshafen mit basf in
etwa die strommenge von acht des neuen
windparks auf see
das klingt viel und das ist es auch
[Musik]
die gute nachricht ist schon vor den
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine hatte die
bundesregierung einen zukunftsplan um
das industrieland deutschland bis 2045
co2 neutral zu machen und dieser brand
gilt heute immer noch mehr als vorher
[Applaus]
dünnes eis auf dem der kanzler da gerade
wandelt bei der ziehung der plan zum co2
in deutschland der basiert im
wesentlichen auch darauf dass
wasserstoff zu einer wasserstoff und
blaue wasser stoppte eines ökologisch
der andere ist nicht ganz so sauber wird
aus gas hergestellt aus russland kommen
soll in 20 15 jahren wie da weiter
gemacht werden soll da sagte kanzler
nicht dann auch da sind in deutschland
russische verankert im wasserstoff
wartet
mit einem eigenen gesetz beschleunigen
wir den ausbau so dass in wenigen
monaten und nicht in jahren und
jahrzehnten die nötige infrastruktur
errichtet wird
erschließen neue bezugsquellen
erst vorige woche habe ich dazu
gespräche in afrika geführt wir reden
auch mit norwegen mit kanada den usa und
katar
und terminals und leistung sondern
künftig auch für wasserstoff genutzt
werden denn darin liegt die zukunft
zweitens der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird massiv beschleunigt
das oster paket ist bereits
verabschiedet zwei weitere pakete folgen
im sommer und herbst und wir wollen die
dauer der verwaltungsverfahren
mindestens halbieren und das
[Applaus]
das will ich an dieser stelle auch sehr
klar sagen
wir werden uns nicht den schneid
abkaufen lassen meine damen und herren
nicht von den lobbyisten nicht von den
bedenkenträgern und auch nicht von den
verteidigern des status quo denn wenn
wir erst einmal anfangen dinge auf die
zeitschiene zu schieben dann werden wir
niemals rechtzeitig fertig werden es ist
zu lang wir haben die zeit dafür nicht
mehr dieses jahr ist das jahr der
entscheidung und die entscheidung werden
die tochter
stolz kann anpacken das hat man bei den
waffenlieferungen wie die ukraine
vermisst ist hier ein ganz klarer ton
ganz klare ansage wir haben zu lange
verfahrenswege wir müssen auch in
energie sachen und woanders müssen wir
jetzt die entscheidung einfach mal
beschleunigen jetzt ist olaf scholz gibt
zumindest hier in togo kanzlerin
wollen wir für die ostsee erreichen und
die kommission hat auch ihren beitrag
geleistet mit dem paket repower you das
dazu beitragen soll dass viele dinge
schneller gehen neben vielen fragen die
jetzt von einigen im vordergrund
diskutiert werden ist ja eine sache
dabei ganz zentral es sollen noch immer
neue möglichkeiten der beschleunigung
beinhalten damit verfahren einfacher
werden und wir die dinge besser
voranbringen können auch darüber haben
wir bei der sondertagung des
europäischen rates gesprochen und es
bleibt ein ziel für ganz europa was für
uns unmittelbar geld wir wollen energie
unabhängigkeit erreichen so schnell wie
möglich das wissen wir ist diesen tagen
ganz ganz dringend angesichts des
russischen angriff
[Applaus]
und wir wollen vollständige co2
neutralität bis 2045 erreichen das ist
machbar beides gehört zusammen es
schließt einander nicht aus und wir
werden beides erreichen
natürlich gehört dazu dass wir auch
jetzt die grundlagen dafür legen all das
voranzubringen was für unser land
wichtig ist bei forschungen innovationen
bei digitalisierung wo wir mehr tempo
brauchen bei der aus und weiterbildung
und deshalb schaffen wir ein
qualifizierungs geld deshalb wollen wir
neue aufstiegsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
chancengerechtigkeit wir schaffen eine
startchance programm wir bauen die
ganztagsbetreuung an schulen aus den
grundschulen die bafög-reform läuft und
wir wollen uns für eine
ausbildungsgarantie einsetzen damit
jugendlichen einen berufseinstieg nicht
verwehrt bleibt alles gastes
investitionen
denn wir brauchen die diese investition
in unsere zukunft wir brauchen die
besten erfinderinnen die weltbesten
ingenieure und gut ausgebildete
facharbeiter rinnen und facharbeiter
ich habe eingangs über die erwartungen
der bürgerinnen und bürger gesprochen
wäre fragen und sorgen die wir in den
mittelpunkt unserer politik stellen und
die aktuell größte sorge ist ganz
unbedingt der furchtbaren krieg den
russland gegen die ukraine begonnen hat
uns alle schmerzen die schmerz die opfer
dieses verbrecherischen krieges der ihn
schon fast 100 tage wird mit jedem tag
steigen die opferzahlen
mit jedem tag werden mehr städte und
orte im trümmerwüste verwandelt
angesichts der russischen bomben und
artillerie und deshalb ist so wichtig
dass wir uns über das einig sind was wir
erreichen wollen putin darf und wird
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
[Applaus]
und es gibt jetzt eine situation in der
immer wieder darüber diskutiert wird was
die kriegsziele sind unsere unser ziel
ist dass putin nicht gewinnt unser ziel
ist dass die ukraine sich verteidigen
kann und damit erfolgreich ist aber ich
will ausdrücklich sagen ich will
ausdrücklich sagen es ist überheblich
und es ist unangemessen und es ist
völlig fehl am platze wenn hier zu lange
darüber diskutiert wird was die ukraine
richtigerweise zu entscheiden hat ich
sage es mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über die ukraine entscheiden
die ukraine ukraine und niemand sonst
erwärmt
das war da eingesprungene doppelchance
und zwar um zu vermeiden dass er sagen
muss die ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen
sagt er wieder mal sein einsatzteam
dahin krieg nicht gewinnen aber nicht
wirken gewinn so und jetzt tut er so als
würden alle anderen leute die sagen die
ukraine muss league gewinnen und sie
bestimmt was ein was ensi für sie ist
als würden die überheblich und
unangemessen agieren und mit argumenten
kommen die viel am klatschen das ist
wirklich der eingesprungene doppel oder
da gibt es den einen oder anderen der
vielleicht auch denkt so könnte das doch
gelingen dann ist die sache endlich
vorbei aber das kann nicht sein wir
werden die ukrainerin ukrainer so lange
unterstützen wie das erforderte erst mit
all den möglichkeiten lieber auf den weg
gebracht haben
[Applaus]
putin darf seine ziele nicht erreichen
er darf nicht mit seinem konzept
durchkommen mit einem brutalen
militärischen einsatz ein land zu
erobern oder teile davon das ist im
realismus und den werden wir in europa
nicht akzeptieren
ja das war jetzt ein dickes ausführung
ausrufezeichen sein sollte ist
eigentlich nur dass imperativ indes nur
fans des new kanzler kanzlers also der
mann der keine schweren panzer in die
ukraine liefert sagt dass das gut dass
die ukraine ihre ziele erreichen muss
schwierig sagen wir mal so um der
kanzler macht spart
dadurch ihre wirksamkeit entfalten diese
geschlossenheit müssen wir bewahren
[Applaus]
und deshalb ist es gut dass
sich der europäische rat erster nach dem
5 4 sanktionspaket die vorher
beschlossen waren auf ein sechstes
verständigt hat mit vielen weiteren sehr
detaillierten sanktionen an dem wir
lange gearbeitet haben und auch mit
einem ölembargo das dazugehört ich bin
froh dass diese entscheidung jetzt
getroffen worden ist
wir steigen zum herz aus dem import
russischer kohle aus und für uns in
deutschland gilt
der kanzler verkauft ja eine europäische
einigkeit dies schlicht und ergreifend
nicht gibt er verweist auf das öl
embargo das beim europäischen rat
beschlossen worden ist gestern zur
erklärung dieses öl embargos in teilen
und es fehlt aber nach dem ersten erst
im nächsten jahres
außerdem unterstützen wir die ukraine
finanziell mit sehr sehr viel mittel
gerade erst haben wir eine milliarde
zugesagt im rahmen der g7 eine direkte
zahlung aus deutschland die dazu
beitragen soll dass die ukraine dieser
situation per werden kann der sie der
gefahr herr werden kann der sie
ausgesetzt ist und
neben der wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen unterstützung
liefern wir auch waffen
eines will ich klarstellen
deutschland muss sich da nicht
verstecken
wir liefern kontinuierlich von beginn
des krieges an
und unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn haben
wir diese entscheidung getroffen und mit
einer langjährigen
praxis in deutschland gebrochen das war
eine richtige entscheidung aber es war
eine mutige neue entscheidung dieser
regierung meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
und weil sie ja nur fragen durch die
landschaft getänzelt sind herr merz noch
mal der hinweis
es ist eine regierung die von der cdu
geführt worden ist die diese stadt ist
die letzten jahre hatte ich will das
nicht kritisieren aber so zu tun als sei
das nicht irgendein ganz besonders
weitreichender schritt gewesen dass wir
das jetzt gemacht haben das ist nicht in
ordnung und auch nicht vernünftig
[Applaus]
und wer kann da schon mal schützen läuft
machte dem nächsten eingesprungenen
doppel und zwar versucht er jetzt die
tatsache dass man zwei wochen liefert
irgendwann mal nach kriegsbeginn hat man
mit leichten waffen angefangen
dass jetzt auch der union anzulasten die
ja vorher dieselbe praxis gehabt haben
mich überhaupt nicht zu liefern das ist
eine grenze der unsittlichkeit damals
gab es keinen totalen an bis jetzt nicht
in diesem ausmaß gab die russische
invasion nicht die russen standen nicht
von tier und sascha kanzler weiterhin
nicht sagt ist auch mal keine schweren
waffen
wenige tage nach kriegsausbruch haben
wir flugabwehrraketen und
panzerabwehrwaffen geliefert also genau
das was zu dem zeitpunkt am dringendsten
nötig war dazu kommen bislang mehr als
15 millionen schuss munition 100.000
handgranaten über 5000 panzer abwärme
umfangreiches sprengmaterial
maschinengewehre dutzende lastwagen
ladungen mit sonstigen relevanten gütern
zb zur drohen abwehr für mobilität
kommunikation und zur verpflegung und
versorgung verwundeter
gemeinsam mit dänemark haben wir der
ukraine auf ihren wunsch in 54
modernisierte gepanzerte
truppentransporter gelegt hat über einen
ersten ringtausch mit unseren
tschechischen freunden bekommt die
ukraine vertraut das gerät britischer
bauart zunächst 20 kampfpanzer t 72 wir
sorgen für ersatz für tschechien weitere
gespräche laufen
erst gestern habe ich mit dem
griechischen ministerpräsidenten
mitsotakis verabredet dass griechenland
schützenpanzer aus ehemaligen informer
beständen liefern wird und wir dafür die
griechischen bestände mit deutschen
schützenpanzern auffüllen und auch das
sollte nicht
vergessen und beiseite getan werden
unser unterstützung gehört und da zeigt
sich der ganze irrsinn griechenland
liefert also darauf verweist der kanzler
schützenpanzerwagen aus ddr zeiten die
also dass sie noch nicht fest gerostet
sind ist ein großes wunder und dafür
gegen die griechen neue fand sie ja
warum gibt man dann nicht gleich direkt
anzeigen die ukraine sind ja auch nicht
blöd zum fahrtraining koste nicht viel
dauert auch nicht lange da zeigt sich
der gesamte irrsinn und da kannst du
natürlich freuen sich die ukraine über
15 millionen schuss munition über panzer
falls alles möglich sein das hilft auch
aber die große hilfe die die ukraine
wollte und darüber deutscher kanzler
hinweg die ukraine wollte panzer die
ukraine hat bestellt er hat nicht
geliefert er hat listen von 800
millionen zusammengestrichen das am ende
von 120 positionen doch über 60 über
geblieben sind deswegen war gut gelaufen
aber es geht weiter
in der letzten woche hat die ukraine den
vertrag mit der rüstungsindustrie über
die gebhard flaig panzer unterzeichnet
die rund dreiwöchige schulung läuft
dieser tage an und
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen die
wurden von der ukraine gewünscht ich
habe in den talkshows dieser republik
gehört das gesagt wurde die wollen das
gar nicht hier im bundestag haben das
auch welche erzählt ganz naseweis haben
sie berichtet wie sie eben über
terminvereinbarung ehrlicherweise dass
barney und zu keinem zeitpunkt richtig
das ist eine hochwirksame eine hoch
schwere waffe um diesen komischen
begriff zu benutzen und sie wird
eingesetzt werden in der ukraine
der eine oder andere könnte ich ja
meinen seine ganzen äußerungen die er da
in der hitze des gefechts in diesem fall
so gesagt hat noch einmal überprüfen da
ist ganz schön viel was einfach mit der
wirklichkeit nichts zu tun hat dabei und
es kommt diese woche mit einer
erstausstattung von 59.000 schuss
munition und das reicht für 1200
bekämpfung vorgänger da habe ich ja auch
wieder welche gehört und gelesen die
gesagt haben dass seine artillerie waffe
mit der man nicht zum beispiel flugzeuge
bekämpft oder drogen die einen bedrohen
sondern das sei etwas das einfach darum
zu nutzen würde in die gegend zu
schießen und anderswohin das ist nicht
richtig gewesen und trotzdem durften
hier leute überall in deutschland diesen
krams erzählen wo leben wir eigentlich
und was macht eigentlich das für einen
sinn
in den kommen in den kommenden wochen
werden wir in der ukraine eng abgestimmt
mit den niederländern 12 der modernsten
panzerhaubitzen der welt liefern die
ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten daran
wird in wenigen tagen abgeschlossen sein
und es sind wirklich sehr moderne waffen
sehr schwere waffen was soll abgesehen
davon dass das abschießen von flugzeugen
mit luftabwehrraketen auch ein schwerer
vorgang ist an der fasnacht ein anderes
schwerer machen seien hoch schwere
waffen man kann damit so in der gegend
rum schießen manchmal hat man
tatsächlich noch aus dass olaf scholz
zivildienst gemacht hat und nicht
wirklich weiß was in der bundeswehr los
ist und was
nicht ist gut wir machen viel lernen
auch neue worte von kanzler
in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländern
wenn wir den kommenden wochen werden wir
auch weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel
hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
ferner werden wir der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ortungs radar liefern das
feindliche auf pizzen mörsern und
raketen atelier aufklärt auch das ist
eine entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben und die die sicherheit der ukraine
mit modernstem gerät sicherstellen wird
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was möglich ist allen
regionen meiden
[Applaus]
und dann muss man ihn kanzler einfach
rein grätschen denn der sagt wir machen
alles das was möglich ist nein das macht
es nicht und das macht vor allem nicht
das was bestellt worden ist es die
listen von der rüstungsindustrie waren
umfangreich diese in seinem kanzleramt
zusammengestrichen worden er macht alles
das was er für möglich hält aber nicht
alles das was möglich ist
mit denen die usa immer eng abgestimmt
handeln das will ich übrigens sagen ist
aus meiner sicht eine wirklich
beeindruckende qualität unserer
transatlantischen beziehungen dass wir
wirklich intensiv miteinander abgestimmt
sind dass wir uns sorgfältig absprechen
dass wir gemeinsam hand und angesichts
der verlagerung des gefechts in den
osten der ukraine hat präsident biden
gesagt
man will über das hinaus was bisher
geliefert worden ist
die möglichkeit nutzen mehrfach
raketenwerfer zur verfügung zu stellen
er hat gesagt er
werde keine waffen liefern den gegner in
der lage wäre nach russland zu schießen
aber das was notwendig ist mit dann in
dieser distanz auch von russland in der
ukraine genutzten deutschen
raketenwerfern das werden die usa tun
wir sind mit ihr seit tagen darüber im
gespräch und wir haben mit den usa
besprochen dass das was dann haben
unsere technischen möglichkeiten ist
auch beigetragen wird auch das hört zu
unseren entscheidungen
[Applaus]
und natürlich ist alleine dieser aufsatz
wert sehr sorgfältig diskutiert zu
werden denn die besonnenheit die
fähigkeit abzuwählen das für und wider
zu
erörtern
das wünschte ich mir auch von der
opposition in diesem deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
wir haben wir jedenfalls im geleitzug
mit unseren verbündeten so habe ich es
oft gesagt und diesen geleitzug habe ich
eben beschrieben er wird auch weiter
unsere politik bestimmen natürlich weiß
ich dass das eine situation ist in der
das für und wider mit großen heißem
herzen erörtert wird aber es gibt auch
klare haltungen dabei und natürlich ist
es gut sich hinzustellen und zudem zu
gehören die immer sagen alles noch mehr
davon noch was davon noch was genau so
wie es ganz einfach ist zu sagen gar
nichts aber das was man tun muss ist
genau der weg den diese regierung
eingeschlagen hat große entschlossenheit
mut und kluge abwägung das ist das
vertreten
und damit bin ich bei dem lieben
kolleginnen kollegen
was wir mit dem sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr erreichen
ziel ist eine leistungsfähige und
fortschrittliche bundeswehr eine
bundeswehr die ihren kernauftrag die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung erfüllen
kann weil sie ausreichend ausgestattet
ist und ich wiederhole was sich am
anfang gesagt habe die versäumnisse der
letzten 16 jahren von csu und cdu
verteidigungsminister und der dortigen
begegnungsstätten die werden jetzt
aufgearbeitet und aufgeholt
das weiß jeder soldaten wetzlar es war
die csu cds und cdu dies spart zeit bei
der bundeswehr begonnen haben das ist
die wahrheit
gleichwohl ich bedanke mich bei allen
die in den letzten tagen mitgeholfen
haben dass wir diese entscheidung
zustande bringen können das so
konstruktiv und da über parteigrenzen
hinweg verhandelt worden ist denn das
was hier hinbekommen ist ein
quantensprung
und es hat noch eine konsequenz
die bundeswehr wird wohl dann die größte
konventionelle armee im europäischen
nato system
und wir werden auch alles dafür
beitragen dass wir uns auch ansonsten
weiter verbessern was unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur betrifft zum
beispiel wenn es um fragen der
cybersicherheit geht und deshalb finde
ich müssen wir den moment der hier
stattfindet auch genau verstehen es ist
anders als in früheren zeiten wo man in
paris und warschau in london in
washington oder prag angst und sorge
hatte wenn die bundeswehr so viel
stärker wahr und die deutsche armee
sondern es ist erleichterung was dort zu
spüren es alle sind sehr beeindruckt von
diesem schritt endlich sagen sie endlich
übernimmt deutschland die für
sicherheitspolitische verantwortung die
es im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
hatte und zwar von einer ampel regierung
angeführt
viele
die richtige antwort auf die zeitenwende
und wir geben sie die wir kolleginnen
und kollegen wir bringen in ordnung was
nicht in ordnung war und deshalb ist es
auch so richtig bei unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten es verdienen dass sie eine
gute bundeswehr haben genauso wie die
bürgerinnen und bürger des landes denn
es geht um sicherheit und wir haben die
verantwortung die sicherheit unseres
landes und unseres bündnisses zu
gewährleisten
vernetzt sie haben darüber berichtet
dass hier als ich das sagte beifall
geklatscht wurde auch aus den reihen
ihrer fraktion dafür bedanke ich mich
wie ich mich übrigens wirklich ernst ich
bedanke dass es möglich war konstruktiv
das ergebnis hier zu verhandeln ich
möchte mich auch bei allen die mit
verhandelt haben intensiv bedanken weil
ich weiß es geht immer auch um konkrete
person in der lage sind dann das zu tun
was notwendig ist aber das
paradies
das will ich an dieser stelle dann doch
auch sagen so zu tun
so zu tun
als wäre das jetzt alles schon mal
passiert weil die rede gehalten wurde
vor drei monaten
das ist ein irrtum das ist die größte
veränderung der sicherheitspolitischen
architektur dieses landes und ich bin
stolz dass wir das diese regierung sie
auf den weg bringen kann ich bin dankbar
dass die opposition dabei hilft
[Applaus]
kleine stunde scholz bürger die
übersetzten mal ganz groß der kanzler
meinte seine eigene rede und friedrich
merz habe ihm unterstellt oder habe
bemängelt dass alles was der kanzler in
seiner zeit einwände rede am 27 februar
angekündigt hatte noch nicht passiert
ist dann so lang dass wir darum
geschmuggelt kurze erklärung von
familien zusammen meinte seine eigene
seniorin testen können noch nicht alles
passiert sein was du damals angekündigt
hat
der sender zum g 7 gipfel in ellmau
eingesehen
denn das darf uns nicht passieren
dass wir diese länder als bündnispartner
verlieren und das ist ja eine große
gefahr angesichts der auswirkungen
dieses krieges der gefahren für hunger
und sicherheit und energie versorgung
dieser länder und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir darüber nicht hinweg sehen der
krieg ist aus der perspektive mancher
dieser länder ganz weit weg aber die
konsequenzen ganz nah wir müssen ihnen
helfen und das werden wir tun in größter
solidarität und gleichzeitig die
botschaft aussenden die auch ausgesandt
werden muss in jedem gespräch es ist
putins krieg der diese krise verursacht
und nichts anderes
[Applaus]
zum schluss
wir leben in einer herausforderung wie
sie die bundesrepublik deutschland noch
nicht in dieser art gekannt hat wir
müssen etwas dafür tun dass wir in
dieser besonderen situation auch
besonders handeln und das durch diese
haushalt auszahlen das sind nicht meine
worte sondern die worte meiner
vorgängerin aus dem jahr 2020
seinerzeit hat die bundeskanzlerin damit
eine neuverschuldung begründet die
deutlich höher lag als die
neuverschuldung im aktuellen
haushaltsentwurf
anders als damals haben wir es heute
allerdings nicht nur mit der pandemie
und ihren folgen zu tun sondern
zusätzlich mit einem krieg in europa mit
einer globalen energie- und
nahrungsmittelkrise und weltweit
steigenden preise in diesen unsicheren
zeiten sorgen wir mit dem haushalt 2022
und dem sondervermögen bundeswehr für
sicherheit und zugleich stellen wir die
weichen für den aufbruch in die zukunft
das erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger
dafür steht die bundesregierung dafür
steht dieser haushalt schön danke
[Applaus]
großen applaus für olaf scholz vor allem
natürlich aus der appelle koalition wir
wollen ist ganz natürlich noch ein
bisschen einordnen peter also sowohl
friedrich merz als auch olaf scholz
haben geliefert muss man sagen wer
besser geliefert sie haben beide für
ihre klientel richtig gut geliefert und
das ist dann tatsächlich auch die gute
nachricht heute wir haben trotz der
krise um diesen krisen tun die im
bundestag in der regel gut ein hauch von
wasserwerk gehabt meine generation
werden und sind noch bonner wasserwerk
das parlament früher und das war wie
früher wie als sich wehner und strauß
und andere da duelliert haben und das
ist gut so das ist gut so dass die ihre
position darlegen jeder kann sich
aussuchen stehe ich auf der seite scholz
oder märz beide waren rhetorisch gut
beide waren wirklich auch argumentativ
gut bei der hanse spagat und pirouetten
gedreht der kanzler ein paar mehr er
kommt nicht drum rum dass er keine
schweren waffen liefert keinen richtig
schweren waffen und das ja nicht sagt
die ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen dann
weiß die maus keinen faden ab und da
kommt da kannst du nicht drumrum gute
stunde fürs parlament und man muss sagen
urlaub war wirklich heute emotionaler
als sonst und auch ein närrischer also
ich hatte zwei kaffee erde
offensichtlich